it's the world's
first fully integrated that's the
multi-processor computer using this
android
software generates real-time 3d graphics
to suit
any application how do we access this
virtual world
[Music]
welcome to the world of virtuality
please select your desired experience
[Music]
and relax in the virtuality sd unit
[Music]
now put on your visit
virtual reality is a technology that's
being developed
at nasa and on the west coast and in
germany
that takes two sony walkman
screens or better equipment if you've
got it
and mounts them in a helmet right here
and then puts a black lace net glove on
your hand
that has sensors at every joint
then this whole thing is under computer
driven
control and when you put the helmet on
and they open the channels you're in
what's called
a vr of virtual reality
it's a reality which doesn't really
exist it's only virtual
but it's sustained as an illusion by
this new form of media
and you can walk around in the virtual
reality
picking things up opening doors
operating machinery and so forth and so
on
now that's the that's the we want to
sell you this stuff
version of it the truth is it's a
hideously
crude insultingly simple-minded
technology
at this point but it holds some kind
of real promise in the future
for an artist to be able to show his
audience
the real state of his imagination
what the cyberpunk generation
holds out to the rest of us is a new
kind of communication
a communication that is like telepathy
because it's seen with the eyes and so
then
it dissolves boundaries and unites us
back into this tribal uh community
that we feel such a need for
i don't see virtual reality as an
entertainment device
so much as a way of perfecting the
project of human communication
and the way to do this is to take
the low bandwidth
signal represented by small mouth noises
and turn it in to a virtual
topology of intentionality make
meaning something that people see rather
than hear
this is what virtual reality holds out
in my mind that's what i'm interested in
virtual reality as anybody who's
experienced it will tell you
is dog [ __ ] compared to five grams of
psilocybin in silent darkness
so for for brice performance it will
never beat acid
but it shows where it should go the the
thing that i
fear for virtual reality is that it will
be a kind of techno masturbation
how do we get the unexpected
the astonishing the utterly
unpredictable and the terrifying
into a loop of what is essentially a
manufactured product put together in
production facilities to
sell the only way this can be done
is if instead of trying to look away
from the psychedelic experience and
assure
everyone that oh no this isn't that god
forbid
this isn't that instead of taking that
approach
say look the core of humanness
is the psychedelic experience any
technology of information transfer
that does not set its sights on
becoming a simulation or a simulacrum
or a take-off on the psychedelic
experience
is leading away from what is human
we could use this to perfect language
into a true telepathic
medium and that that's what we're going
to have to have to save ourselves
we must change our minds and all this
stuff about fixing nuclear power plants
and better pornography and all that
is just fluff and spin off as far as i'm
concerned
there's a mission here and a grail to be
pursued
that's the one one thing i wanted to
leave you with and the other
is deepening the community
deepening the community so that
we are not pulled in all directions
when this thing becomes inevitably as
big as it will be
if we keep to the vision the moment has
now come
to bring in the playwrights
the artists the designers the architects
have already been involved
but people in the arts need both to be
informed that this is going on
and they have to bring their insights
into this community
otherwise as one of the speakers said
tonight
we're in danger of seeing it just be
turned into three-dimensional computer
games
well as i was driving down here today i
heard
uh i was listening to the radio and i
heard
a living color sing a song
which says everything is possible
nothing is real
and my mind supplied the next two lines
which were
everything is virtual but what can you
feel
it's always held against the technical
community that somehow
we've moved beyond the values of the
natural
and the biological world but if you
think about
what the tools of cyberspace
are they are integrated circuits
chips and electronic components which
are made of gold
platinum arsenic silver copper
silicone these are all the materials of
the earth and in a sense what we are
doing
is organizing the raw material
of the earth so that it can reflect
the dynamics of electrons
of light moving through fiber optic
cables
so really the in in the cybernetic
revolution
what is happening is a kind of
completion
of the dream of alchemy that spirit
could actually commingle
with metals and glass
and that out of this mingling
of spirit and matter could come
a new possibility a new
evolutionary option a kind of
philosopher's stone
a kind of panacea at the end of time
and this is to me what the computer and
the virtual technologies
all push toward a kind of mirroring
of our own souls
[Music]
it's almost as though our physiology
makes virtual reality our destiny
[Music]
unifying is what this technology holds
out as an ultimate possibility
although on what scale what time scale
this unity will arrive is hard to say
can you imagine if
you could see what i mean how
close that would make us how in fact if
you could see
what i mean we would be the same person
that's why when we talk about perfected
speech
someone doing a good job talking we say
he spoke clearly it's a visual metaphor
or we say to them i
see what you mean i see what you mean
means that for us authentic meaning is
beheld
this is because this is how we did it
until we fell into history
history is the realm of the lower
dimensional language slice
among other things
[Music]
so i think what we we need to recapture
the conspiratorial ambiance of
the dope dealing past that we
keep trying to leave behind
[Music]
you